[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes en la redacción
de france 24 hoy los llevaremos a irak
algunas mujeres en irak han comenzado la
lucha por tomar el control de sus
derechos y libertades las iraquíes
representan un 40 y 9.4 por ciento casi
la mitad de la población y sin embargo
en las calles los cafés los restaurantes
y también en las escuelas o en el
trabajo los hombres predominan sólo el
14 por ciento están empleadas en
comparación con el 73 por ciento de los
hombres según cifras de la onu la causa
es que es una sociedad ultra
conservadora en lugar de buscar una
educación superior o una carrera las
mujeres deben permanecer en la casa a
salvo de las miradas ajenas las que
quieran acabar con estas tradiciones se
enfrentan al peligro violencias
domésticas matrimonios forzados crímenes
de honor violaciones las amenazas son
múltiples frecuentes y ampliamente
aceptadas por estos riesgos algunas
iraquíes han decidido luchar contra
estas normas y darle paso a un
movimiento feminista en el país
en las calles las militantes de esta
causa pasan desapercibidas pero no
pierden la esperanza de ser las pioneras
de una sociedad más igualitaria nuestros
reporteros lucille waserman y jack
johnson acompañaron a tres de estas
mujeres en bagdad aquí la historia
[Música]
me llamo raya calipso y abogada de
militante feminista en irak la ley está
retrocediendo en cuanto a la protección
de las mujeres estamos gobernadas por la
vergüenza la vergüenza y la vergüenza
que vergüenza mujer que manejes un auto
que vergüenza que trabajes que vergüenza
que vayas a la escuela en esta sociedad
iraquí ultraconservador a las mujeres
son constantemente marginadas aquí ser
feminista significa enfrentarse a las
costumbres y tradiciones una lucha
arriesgada que algunas iraquíes como
rush ya han decidido llevar a cabo
[Música]
y nos dirigimos hacia la estación de
policía de alcanza ubicada en el barrio
de al ubaidi un barrio popular y tribal
donde las mujeres no circulan a su
antojo por las calles hoy raya acompaña
a una de sus clientas para su segunda
reunión en la comisaría esta víctima de
violencia conyugal afirma haber tenido
un aborto y un accidente cerebrovascular
tras las repetidas violencias de su
marido por razones de seguridad no
revelaremos su identidad la llamaremos
sara cual cree que será la reacción de
su familia
creo que llamarán a las tribus para
ejercer presión sobre mí mi exmarido no
se presentará en la comisaría
si no me atengo a las decisiones de mi
tribu y hago valer mis derechos hablarán
mal de mí y pondrán a mi familia en mi
contra
mi familia me golpearía sino por beth
con bauza de paren aleje sara está
ansiosa durante su primera reunión los
policías la acusaron de estar mintiendo
estigmatizadas juzgadas menospreciadas
más del 97% de las mujeres afirman no
estar listas para presentar denuncias en
jacques al llegar a la comisaría ya no
tenemos autorización para seguir
filmando ese día los policías tenían que
haber detenido al ex marido de sarah
pero declararon que no se encontraba en
su casa y varias semanas después de esta
tentativa el hombre aún no había sido
detenido sara aceptó volver a reunirse
con nosotros y dejarnos filmar su
encuentro con raya cuando él la golpeaba
cómo reaccionaba su familia
como reaccionado a su familia bueno
cuando él me golpeaba ellos miraban nada
más para estas mujeres víctimas de
violencias conyugales existen pocas
soluciones en irak la mayor parte de los
refugios son ilegales y suelen estar en
la mira de las autoridades sin
esperanzas sara afirma haber tratado
acabar con su vida usted trató de
suicidarse
como trato de hacerlo
rompió un jarrón y tomé un pedazo de
vidrio
me corté la avena y le dije que me
llevara con mi familia
a partir de ese momento cuando las
personas se enteran de que trate de
suicidarme y dicen que soy una buena
persona
no piensan estaba desesperada porque su
esposo la golpeaba con una barra de
hierro y quería matar al bebé que tenía
en su vientre no
después de eso fuimos al hospital con su
familia y ellos dijeron que me había
cortado de la mano con una ventana rota
registraron que se trató de un intento
de suicidio no
honestamente me siento triste y a veces
siento rabia hay un gran vacío a nivel
legislativo
necesitamos otras leyes para responder a
los desarrollos de nuestra sociedad
desafortunadamente en irak el poder
tribal supera la autoridad legal
[Música]
son tal cada día
las leyes tribales no son el único
obstáculo para estas mujeres que piden
derechos y libertad incluso en los
lugares más tolerantes de la capital las
iraquíes deben enfrentar el yugo de una
sociedad patriarcal
my name es mark twain
me llamo marcel y para mí el feminismo
es sencillamente ser humano es una
palabra que se puede encarnar que se
puede vivir sin importar que seas hombre
o mujer todos deberíamos ser feministas
todos deberíamos luchar por nuestros
derechos
marcelina no es su verdadero nombre pero
es el que ella escogió y bajo el cual
las personas la conocí con su estilo
fuera de lo común nunca pasa
desapercibida en bagdad
esa es una de las diferencias aquí en
irak simplemente porque soy mujer las
personas piensan asia pero porque tiene
tantos piercings porque tiene un tatuaje
hasta las mismas mujeres pueden ser las
primeras enemigas de las mujeres la
sorprendía a veces cuando escucho que
alguna me dice eres una mala mujer
porque te ves así
encontrar vías de escape no es fácil en
irak incluso en el corazón de las noches
iraquíes la generación joven puede ser
muy conservadora
cuando vas a una fiesta hay personas que
se impresionan al verte ahí dicen cosas
como espera hay una mujer aquí que hace
aquí piensan que las mujeres solamente
deberían quedarse en casas aprender a
cocinar te hará un hijo y cuidarte los
hombres
[Música]
uno de los pocos ambientes donde
marcelín se siente cómoda es con la
pequeña comunidad lgtb de bhakta son
jóvenes iraquíes que viven
contracorriente en esta sociedad
conservadora en irak varios han muerto a
causa de su orientación sexual no
mostraremos ningún rostro de los
participantes de esta fiesta
si uno no se siente seguro en su propio
país a su propia nación en su propia
casa donde podrá entonces encontrar paz
sé mi familia se entera de que estoy
aquí me matarán eso es seguro o tendré
muchos problemas y me privaron de todo
porque estamos en una sociedad
literalmente enferma ni siquiera se
acepta que las mujeres pueden ser libres
marcheline decidió acabar con los
dictámenes de la sociedad iraquí cuando
su madre quiso divorciarse en 2016 ese
día su padre tomó por asalto su casa
junto con sus parientes para oponerse a
esa decisión
en un momento dado escuché a unas
personas entrar a la casa
se oía como si hubiera mucha gente
escuché muchos gritos y luego muchos
disparos y pensé pero qué está pasando
aquí
nadie resultó herido tras el incidente
pero el padre de marcelino se la llevó
al norte de irak le confiscó su
pasaporte y todavía no lo recupera
yo no quiero vivir así no quiero estar
enjauladas solo porque no acepto sus
ideas creo que fue en ese momento cuando
empecé a definirme como feminista porque
tuve que luchar por mis derechos a hard
fight for my rights desde entonces
marcelín se reunió con su madre en
bagdad que vive en un apartamento
sencillo y gracias a un trabajo en un
ministerio algo fuera de lo común en
irak donde sólo el 2% de las mujeres
cabeza de familia tienen un empleo
estable ahora la madre de marcelino
quiere darle la educación que ella jamás
recibió liberada de las normas iraquíes
me gusta el arte el canto y el teatro
por lo tanto todas esas cosas las tenía
prohibidas
me encanta ver que ella es la artista
que yo jamás pude ser no quiero ser como
mi propia madre de hecho quiero ser todo
lo contrario
después de 2016 se dio cuenta de que
somos un equipo
luchamos la una por la otra
en ese momento entendí que no era la
única feminista aquí mi madre también es
feminista
incluso en el corazón de bagdad en los
barrios menos conservadores se necesita
valentía y determinación para
reivindicar sus derechos siendo una
mujer que ocurre entonces en los
segmentos más radicales de la sociedad
[Música]
me acuerdo de un adolescente con la que
hablé tenía unos 16 años me contactó por
internet en medio de la noche al
comienzo tenía muchas dudas me dijo
miriam me gustaría contarte algo que me
pasó y luego me explicó que estaba
haciendo a causada por su hermano en su
casa sabes que hizo su madre cuando se
enteró la llevó a un médico para
comprobar si aún seguía siendo un virgen
de manera paralela a su trabajo como
funcionaria pública mariam samir ha
establecido contacto con cientos de
mujeres que viven en los barrios más
conservadores de irak ante sus
testimonios decidió realizar unos
talleres de escritura como éste para
animarlas a expresarse
y me llamo usará tengo 20 años y
cumpliré 21 en agosto tengo muchos
problemas para venir aquí mi familia me
preguntó si habría una cámara
ah
empecé estos talleres en aiaf porque es
considerada una provincia religiosa y
cerrada allí las personas lo ven todo a
través del prisma de la religión así que
fui y las mujeres con las que me
encontré me dijeron pero qué van a decir
las personas y llevamos nuestra
vestimenta tradicional y aparecemos en
un vídeo que asistimos a un taller a un
seminario así que les contesté utilizar
una vestimenta no da fin a una cultura
pueden ponerse una valla o el hub y ser
educadas eso no debe detener las rompan
las barreras desde entonces maría ha
organizado decenas de talleres en 18
provincias de irak para permitir que las
mujeres puedan compartir sus historias y
también contar la suya turistas y jugué
miren por ejemplo a mi hermano no estoy
de acuerdo con él porque no sabe cómo
tratar a las mujeres
porque le dan celos a la mujer
no es eso digamos que tiene una
mentalidad cerrada y no logró
convencerlo de pensar de manera distinta
al provenir también de una familia
conservadora mariam 7 legitimidad para
hablar con estas mujeres en 2019 e
incluso una nueva frontera al participar
en una conferencia difundida a nivel
internacional a pesar de la
desaprobación de su familia hizo una
conferencia entera en la que hable
acerca de todo lo que sufrí en mi
familia y como lo supere ese vídeo
influyó en muchas niñas siempre digo el
problema no son necesariamente las
familias sino las raíces que están
omnipresentes que nosotros
marian ya no lleva la cuenta de los
enfrentamientos que ha tenido con sus
padres pero espera que un día entiendan
las razones de su activismo
menezes
m
me gustaría que puedan sentir el valor
de lo que amo hacer
porque sé que me quieren y yo también
los quiero
y creo que tienen miedo pero no he hecho
nada malo nunca haré nada mal
[Música]
con cerca de dos entre tres mujeres que
se consideran inferiores a los hombres
en irak el feminismo aún tiene un largo
camino por recorrer en el país en las
calles las militantes de esta causa
pasan desapercibidas pero no pierden la
esperanza de ser las pioneras de una
nueva sociedad más igualitaria a pesar
de las críticas y los riesgos que esto
representa para sus vidas
hasta aquí reporteros en la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar este y los
programas anteriores puede ingresar a
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]